[موسيقى]
اتصل
بالوزير الاول
محمد الغنوشي محمد الغنوشي
متواصله الجلسه لزمن غير طويل كنت موجوده
ان كنتم موجوده
في نهايه العمرانيه
بحكم ان الدستور يفرض انك في حاله الطوارئ
يكون القياده للقوات
الامن والجيش كلها تحت امره
الرئيس اركان
الجيش انا ذاك
الجنرال رشيد عمار بحيث يتولى الاشراف على
قاعات العمليه في وزاره الداخليه
وفي وزاره الدفاع بطبيعه الحال التي هي
وزارته
وحتى قاعه العمليات بتاع الامن الرياسي
الجمهوريه انذاك للوزير الاول
والخليه الازمه والقياده الامنيه يعني سيد
عمار
بالتحديد ساعه منهج الجوالان حسب مقتضيات
العالم
[موسيقى]
قبل يوم الرئيس زين العابدين بن علي قد
حله الحكومه صحيح
وقرر تكليف السيد محمد غنوشي
لتكوين حكومه جديده لم يعطيها عنوان
بعد بعد الرئيس رجعت الى مكتبي وانتهى كما
تقولون في الشرق الدوام يعني حاسه العمل
يعني يوم الجمعه تنتهي في بعد منتصف
النهار يعني في الظهر الساعه 1:30
الى المنزل
في المساء يعني في العشيه مش في المساء
[موسيقى]
مع متابعه ما يجري ذلك
تحدثت انا وبعض الاصدقاء
ان يبدا السيد الوزير الاول محمد الغنوشي
بالاتصال باحزاب المعارضه والمنظمات
الوطنيه
والهياكل
المختلفه التي لها سئلته بالعمل السياسي
[موسيقى]